But you did my cheek swab. You indicated cause was toxicity in the past. You've been more specific
So do you know what kind of toxicity? It's been I've been on
Biders for two years. So I'm wondering why it's popping up now
Well, I I don't know why you know, so when I do a cheek swab test sometimes people go
Well, why did that show up? Why are you putting me on this? I've never been on this before
I'm just relaying the information here don't to give out at the messenger
So this is just what came up in your test team
The other way to find out more specifically what type of toxicity would be to do some toxicity panels now
You started with us a long time ago the person who asked this question
Currently people that start with us. We highly recommend that we get toxicity panels. So doing the talks detect
Test, it's a urine test doing the mycotoxin test would be a good thing to do if you haven't done those
I don't know if you've done those. I know you're going to other practitioners as well
So those would be some things to help uncover different toxins
I may do it foot baths
For about a year in light of this toxicity should I go back to doing them?
You can't I'm not a huge fan of the eye on pro wave and pulling out toxins
I would say you if you have a soda or it's coming into the summer if you can sweat that would be better
That's just my opinion